business is not hard even in the medical
world it's really not hard a got to be
competent and you know what most of the
time when people are competent it's not
cause they're geniuses just cause they
give a rip just care and nothing is more
aggravating for any of us than to come
across somebody supposedly in front of
us to do something that just doesn't
care their body language the eye roll
it's just you know they just don't care
I mean you run into this you know the
big joke is always that it's not always
true for you poor people that work there
but the DMV right I mean it's like oh
yeah you're here to bother me I have to
sit here in this chair all day long and
deal with all these people you know that
you know and you just you're dealing
with somebody that just hates their life
hates their job and you know I got to
tell you it's part of what's problem
it's part of what the problem of health
care costs are is that right there is
that $1,000 ambulance ride maybe but now
we've got another thousand dollars in
man-hours and you've got a customer
which by the way that is your customer
pissed off for life you know it's just
it's ridiculous so you think about that
if you're running a business and by the
way you think about that if you work for
someone my friend rabbi Daniel lapin
wrote the book is it on the doc serious
rabbi a wonderful book called thou shall
prosper he said one of the reasons that
Jewish people have a tendency to prosper
is they feel like when they've gotten
got a job that they are in business for
themselves but they just have one
customer they're in business for
themselves but they just have one
customer so if you work for someone
you're in business for yourself and that
company you work for is your only
customer
how are you treating your customer
what's your attitude when you walk in
how are you dressed
how much do you care when you're doing
your job it's really not rocket science
is it we at the end of the day we are
all self-employed at the end of the day
we work for ourselves and what is your
brand what does your personal brand look
like inside the organization and for the
customers that that organization serves
do you just in here and that goes so far
people just care I could put up a lot of
stuff if somebody just cares if you can
go you can you can just you can go a
long way with folks you can go a long
way people you disagree with even if you
don't like them as long as they care
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
you